[VIOLIN MUSIC PLAYING]
Well, MIT is a very
different kind of institute.
Instead of becoming the
recipients of building industry
culture, we can now
change building industry
by the kinds of experiments
we're doing in school.
MIT has a variety
of departments that
are so powerful that they have
the potential of radicalizing
what we do in design and in
the architecture department.
Even the way that we've
structured our curriculum
around workshops and other
kinds of collaborations
foster and encourage this kind
of cross disciplinary platform.
So you're situated
perfectly for the kinds
of things that only MIT can do.
[CHIME]
[BIRDS CHIRPING]
The invention of human
artifacts of any kind
always consists of three
elements, the geometry,
the process, and the material
that constitute that artifact.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
It's very clear that new
materials engender new forms,
and architectural
design benefits
from addressing, applying new
materials in an informed way.
The Emergent Materials Group
and the Urban Metabolism Group
share a central
interest in materials
for the built environment.
Lately, we've been working a
great deal in the area of foam
to materials, especially
foam cements and concretes.
So typically a
beam in bending is
going to have the greatest
amount of stresses
on the top and bottom.
So we can reduce the
amount of material
on the interior of a beam.
The work really tries
to address that there's
two main paradigms throughout
almost every industry.
One paradigm is
what can you design.
What can you compute or analyze?
And the other paradigm is what
can you physically construct,
or what can you build.
The work really tries to
traverse all scale lengths.
It tries to work from
the nanoscale, which
is traditionally where we see
self-assembly and biological
examples, chemical examples.
And it tries to
bridge that and say,
can't we use this
phenomenon of self-assembly
as a new paradigm for building
things at large scale.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We work with any type of
material, synthetic or natural
materials, and really try to
design specific geometries that
have materials in mind.
And when you design
those two together,
they can respond to energy,
and the energy sources
can be heat, shaking, gravity,
pneumatics, electronics.
So you can use any
type of energy,
and when you mix that with
the geometry and material
properties, then
they can respond
and they can change state.
Primarily, it will
first be applied
in extreme
environments-- scenarios
where it's difficult to build.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The research and the
practice is really
about cross-disciplinary
collaborations
between designers,
scientists, engineers,
working on this phenomenon
of self-assembly,
discovering where we
find it naturally,
where we can use
it synthetically,
and trying to apply that at
all different scale lengths.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The focus of our work, at
least at the smaller scale,
at the scale of say art
installations or retail,
we leverage CNC
fabrication methods,
but not as a way to exude
their prowess necessarily,
but more as a way to help us get
at a particular formal agenda.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We have an installation
called Totems which in a way
is a kind of
proto-architecture--
not quite architectural,
not quite sculptural,
but I think that it
offers a proposition
to each of those disciplines.
We do a lot of
testing via 3D prints.
A lot of the formal
investigations for Totems,
specifically,
happened in 3D prints.
We did maybe 30 to 50 3D
prints of the Totems as a way
to understand how light
and shadows were working,
and how best the
anamorphic effects were
working before we went to
the large format wire cutter.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In terms of collaborations, some
of those happen here at MIT.
Joel Lamere and I are
developing an installation now
which is an anechoic chamber.
And the anechoic chamber
uses industrial felt,
both on its exterior and
as a way to absorb sound
on the interior.
I'm bringing a kind
of disciplinary,
or formal, or geometric
interest on the one hand,
also a certain set of
specialized understandings
of the behavior of the sheet
materials on the other.
So my architectural
interests are really broad,
but in terms of my current
research preoccupation
it's about material
geometry, specifically
sheet shapes or sheet
material geometries.
How they bend,
stretch, stack, fold.
But obviously understanding
sheet materials
is really critical
to architecture.
This is sort of a long standing
discourse on sheet materials
and architecture in
part because it's
so ubiquitous in
conventional construction
so everything, including
plywood, sheet metal, steel,
aluminum, plastics,
all of these have
to deal with the developable
surface geometries which is
to say sheet shapes generally.
And so expanding the total set
of understandings about sheet
shapes is a totally,
and kind of obviously,
worthwhile architectural
undertaking.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
These installations
attempt to jump
from the scale of
the paper model
to the scale of the
architectural space at the very
least.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Well, over the past 20
years, first as Office dA now
as NADAAA, we've identified
two or three areas of focus.
The first has been to look at
materials and their behavior
as a point of departure for
many of the architectural
experiments we do.
The second area is to
recognize that materials
don't have an endless limit.
Everything comes in
modules, in sheets,
in blocks, in bricks, and that
without aggregation, there's
no way of beginning to figure
out how construction works
in general.
So the detail of
bringing things together,
as a point of departure, has
been another central focus.
So this has been a
point of revolution
for a range of projects
that we've researched
and undertaken,
some of which are
at the scale of a
piece of furniture,
others that are at the
scale of a building,
and others that are really
at the scale of urbanism.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
One of the agendas
of the studio is
to create interactive
architectures for public space
through design and technology.
And these projects
can range and scale
from the scale of the body,
such as the Defensible Dress
Project, which is a
wearable architecture which
uses a microcontroller
and shape memory
alloys to defend
your personal space,
to very public scale
infrastructure projects,
such as our proposal for the
Audi Urban Futures Initiative
where we're speculating on high
speed regional infrastructure
and transformations in
the city around issues
of mobility for the year 2030.
It seems now more
and more necessary
that our environments have
to become smarter, more
responsive, and more flexible.
The way in which
architecture is made
needs to be completely
rethought if we're
to go beyond bricks and mortar
to engage the challenges
of the next century.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
My work as an architect
focuses on designing
architecture and urban
scale interventions that
engage the emergent
infrastructure of our time.
We're interested in how
design engages that mutability
between energy and matter--
when materials generate
energy or store it,
when materials are
dynamic and change state,
exchange heat, produce light,
or communicate information.
The challenge, I think, for
the discipline of architecture
today isn't in
digital fabrication,
it's in the material
fabrication.
In thinking about what it
means to be material today,
when we move fluidly between
digital and physical realms,
how we use materials
and not waste them,
and how we form materials,
and how we transport them.
If we're going to change
the building industry
and regenerate an
innovation-based manufacturing
segment in the
United States, then I
think we need to do this
from within practice,
from working with the norms
of the building industry,
but not settling
for those norms.
Instead innovating to
both accept and transform
those standard conditions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I think we're pursuing
several initiatives relating
with computation material
at several different areas.
Dynamic interactivity
is one type of surface
and we're driving that forward.
Imagining actively alloplastic
environments, if you like,
it's a demonstration
of the power
of computation come real time.
Then in the robotic
manufacturing work,
we're looking for power
information and material
all coming together with control
directly at the architect's
workplace.
So we're developing tools
that allow architects
within their native
software, like Rhino to pilot
a powerful production
machine like a KUKA
robot demonstrating,
I think, what
will be the future of
manufacturing which
is sophisticated algorithms
and modeling that link directly
to sophisticated
manufacturing machines
and allow both new efficiencies
but new versatilies, new form
of complexities.
I'm also frustrated by the
slowness of the building
industry to innovate materially.
There's a fantastic amount of
research in material science
that's pent up and it's
just dying to come.
At a period where the
environmental concerns are
becoming so enormous and
the challenge of building
the developing world is so
extraordinary and necessary.
CAD Cam meets material
science, like composites,
I think is going to
breathe a whole new life
into the architectural
and building industries.
[MUSIC PLAYING]